alright we got a seal he's an actor
producer and iconic references for shark
album from 1991 death certificate is now
rereleased in a 25th anniversary edition
with three new songs Ice Cube
[Applause]
okay
all right so I know you're here to
promote an album I know you also want to
talk about my transgression what do you
want to do first I knew you was gonna
[ __ ] up sooner or later I did I love
your show
you got a great show thank you you know
uh would you be bucking up against that
line a little bit you know you got a lot
of black jokes you know I'm saying you
do well it's against races uh yeah
sometimes you sound like a redneck
trucker no I don't figure that I got to
do no I don't that I got to push back
all right it's my opinion okay it is my
friend never heard that opinion before
but my thing is this you know and I'm
cool with you I like this show to be
honest I just want to know two questions
what made you think that it was cool to
say that you know I just want quite I
just explained it there was no thought
put into it obviously I was telling dr.
Dyson comedians they react and it was
wrong and I apologized and you know that
is more than that I can't do I accept
your apology but I still think we need
to get to the root of the psyche because
I think it's a lot of guys out there who
cross the line cuz they a little too
familiar or they think they too familiar
or is guys that you know I might have a
black girlfriend the two that made him
kool-aid every now and then and they
think they can cross the line and they
can you know it's a word that has been
used against us it's like a knife man
and you can use it as a weapon
or you can use it as a tool it's been
used as a weapon against us by white
people and we're not going to let that
happen again
by nobody because it's not cool
now I know you heard it's in the instant
a lexicon everybody talking but that's
our word now that's our word now and you
can't have it back I know they trying to
get it back it's guy and I'm not talking
about you bill I'm not talking about you
bill okay but I'm talking about guys who
cross the line every day because they
got some black homies they got some
friends they think it's cool and it's
not cool because when I hear my homey
said it don't feel like venom when I
hear white person said it feel like that
knife stabbing me even if they don't
mean it so you know I like your show and
it's a great show and I just don't know
sometimes is this a political show or is
it a show about jokes and sometimes it's
sometimes the jokes I know understand
that the format and you know you gotta
say it's a comedian show but this to me
is a political show and I think you just
have to uh not step on some of the
political messages that you're saying
with a joke because something is just
ain't funny you know I mean some this is
real right here are we going through and
I'm not trying to get on your case bill
I'm telling you I like your show I like
you but I think this is a teachable
moment not just to you but to the people
that's watching right now I'm not okay
but I think the people watching right
now are saying that point has been made
not by me okay all right all right now
but you bet you've made it and I made it
I made it I'm done and we can laugh now
we can tell joking would you like to I
mean I agree why IceCube said but
furthermore I also think it's about the
context in which the joke was made like
we know you apologize but in the context
you were you essentially by referring to
yourself as a house anything you tended
to whitewash who was really enslaved in
the house you know as a white person in
America you would have been the master
the slave owner
not someone enslaved in the house and it
was mostly black women who were enslaved
in the house who were raped who were
beaten daily day in and day out they
endured physical
mental abuse and so for a lot of people
in America that was like a slap in the
face to black America particularly to
black women and so I with ice Cuban dr.
Dyson this is a teachable moment and in
the teachable moment we have to talk
about just educating and taking it
farther look this is on the backdrop we
are two years shy of the 400th
anniversary of the first 20 African
people being brought to this continent
as slaves we this is on the backdrop of
Confederate monuments of the Confederacy
being taken down from Charlottesville
Virginia to New Orleans Louisiana people
protested about it we gotta fight white
folks on taking down the statute of the
Confederacy this is on the backdrop of
right here in our laying out two weeks
ago when LeBron James will call the
n-word one of the most powerful people
and most known people in the world and
so I it's a teachable moment for
everyone to understand that it is more
than just a word black people are
literally fighting the systems of white
supremacy and institutionalized racism
every single day and we every single day
it does not matter how much money we
make what job we do I have I was
literally on the campaign trail with
Bernie Sanders I was attempted to be
yanked out the entourage for no other
reason except I was a black woman
walking with Bernie that is an issue and
so we have to remember that we still
have some work to do and we still got
some farther places to go maybe when you
take group field trips fall down for
next movies you have an American history
and culture we don't just do it because
to put some some visuals to the things
which all right can we plug your record
before we run out yeah yeah let's plug
the record man it's a great record it is
a great record it was a great record 25
years ago it's been released with three
new songs
yeah so the injustice that you were
shining a light on 25 years ago what is
your assessment of progress in that 25
years only thing change really is the
calendar you know what has changed
though you know to be honest is the
scrutiny of law enforcement
you know before before NWA and before we
did [ __ ] the police then
and what happened was the police could
do no wrong if they saw you in court and
they pointed you out you were guilty you
know after that song and after riding
King you know you saw the police being
more scrutiny they're there on trial now
for for their conduct and we're getting
real to the bottom of some of this it's
low justice but it's moving in the right
direction
and and what about now there's a song
here your new one you know good cop bad
cop yeah okay from the guy who did [ __ ]
the police
yeah what what is your what are you how
do you assess the LAPD I mean it must be
awkward if you get pulled over no no
they got you know it it's actually you
know they they treat me a bit better of
course with me you know they know I got
lawyers it's like that now but I mean
like general are they better don't know
how many five years ago later you know
okay I can't I can't say you know
because I don't get pulled over all the
time but the thing is is you know good
cop bad cop is we appealing to the good
cops out there turn these dudes in man
turn these [ __ ] against the bad
cop we sick of it what they doing is a
turning are they turn in this community
against the police department and the
black community understands the police
department understands why they're there
really like good cops
it's just imbalance those bad feeds
those bad apples you know and the good
cops is now our last line of defense
you know so that's what I want I want
the good cops to start getting these bad
apples out the bunch